well it might be at first glance
easier perhaps in an area like ours food
agriculture and so on but if you really
dig into it you will also see that for
example agriculture the way it is
handled today is not sustainable and
that we will have to make major efforts
especially in the area of agriculture in
order to make it sustainable one of the
main issues is water now you're talking
about energy and the question is of
course all the time and main energy is
not sustainable
well let me say I personally believe
that we will be not running out of
fossil energy because I strongly believe
that we will invent new technologies you
see we didn't leave the Stone Age
because there were no stones anymore in
this world and I'm quite sure we are not
going to leave the fossil oil age that
we have basically enjoyed for the last
100 150 years because it will not be oil
available I think we will leave oil in
the ground because we will have more
efficient and different types of
energies so I think sustainability
should be at a nice business
consideration strategies
the water issue to make it very simple
is a falling one yeah yeah we need about
five liters of water to be able to
sustain our life we need about 20 litres
25 litres for minimum hygiene this is 25
litres okay this is what what I would
call is a social product and there's a
social product you can also call it it
is even human rights now that is one
thing but then we are using about 200 to
5 to 500 liters water per capita and per
day for the other things it in our
household which is for car washing for
dish washing for the gardens and so on
now this part already I don't think is a
human right I think this is we are using
a commercial good that should have a
good price because if it has a good
price we are going to take care of it a
little bit better now
household alone only takes 10 percent of
the total freshwater withdrawal so we
are talking here 10 percent 20 percent
of the water
fresh water is being be strong for
industry for production for energy
construction so and so on and 70 percent
of all fresh water is withdrawn for
agriculture
now agriculture uses ninety-three
percent of all fresh water because
industry and households give a big part
of the water back they have to be
treated but they come they come back in
the in the in the agriculture we use it
basically for the production of food so
while we are drinking five litres of
water per day and we are using 20 liters
of water for minimum hygiene we are
eating every single day somewhere
between 3,000 to 6,000 liter of water
because we need one litre for the pro
calorie that we eat if that calorie
comes from vegetable so from grain but
if this one calorie comes from an animal
we need ten liters of water so therefore
the most important part in the water
issue is to see how
we are using water and agriculture
that's where we have to look at and
unfortunately we are using water and
agriculture in a very very inefficient
way why well one of the main reason is
that water in most parts of the world
for agriculture is a free good and
doesn't have any price
so in today's world already we are
overusing water in a substantial manner
we have several big rivers Rio Grande
I'm sorry which are not bringing one
drop of water into the oceans because
agriculture is using it in a non
sustainable manner so this will have a
major impact on the food security of
this world because at the same time as
our productivity agriculture
productivity goes backwards and we have
this enormous lack of water we have an
increasing population just to give you
two figures every second I talk to
people more to be fed and 0.2 hectare of
arable land less available okay
due to urbanization and to to erosion so
those are the big challenges and that's
why I believe that water by far is a
biggest challenge that humankind has in
the next 10 to 15 years